sowas wollen wir beibehalten was wollen
wir verändern nachdem was wir heute
gesprochen haben beibehalten wollen wir
dass wir alles weiter für das vertrauen
tun so wie ich es gesagt habe ein
wirklich wichtiger punkt den wir bis
jetzt immer auch ins auge gefasst haben
war der freie warenverkehr darum haben
uns die hersteller heute noch mal sehr
gebeten man kann mehr transparenz
herstellen aber die lieferketten sind
sehr verwoben in der europäischen union
raus aus der europäischen union wieder
zurück in die europäische union
es sind viele viele schritte bis zu
einem stoff entsteht dann wollen wir uns
weiter daran halten an die priorisierung
die uns die ständige impfkommission
vorgegeben hat und ich glaube
transparenz auch bei den gesamten
verenden ist weiter ist das allerhöchste
gebot
wir wollen dann etwas verändern weil die
länder mit recht gesagt haben
wir brauchen im grunde ein gutes
management für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wann die impftermine vergeben
werden können es gibt eine nationale
impfstrategie die ist zwischen dem
bundesgesundheitsminister und den
bundesländern entwickelt worden
diese nationale impfstrategie wird jetzt
auch einen nationalen impfplan enthalten
und entsprechend diesen plan deren wir
jeweils nach bestem wissen über die
liefertermine und das was kommen kann
voraussagen was bedeutet dass und da wo
man es noch nicht voraussagen kann und
sagt heute keiner für das zweite quartal
kein hersteller in welchen liefermengen
er pro woche die lieferung machen wird
sie haben uns auch ganz deutlich gesagt
warum das nicht da wo das nicht geht
werden wir modellieren wir werden sagen
kommen die dinge wochen gleich pro monat
kommen sie vielleicht ende des monats
und die verschiedenen szenarien
miteinander entwickeln um einfach auch
mehr sicherheit zu geben wie dann das
einladungsmanagement für die menschen im
land
erfolgen kann entlang der
prioritätenliste der ständigen
impfkommission
das war glaube ich heute auch
übereinstimmt so so dass ich da und das
wir haben verabredet dass die arbeiten
an diesem nationalen impfplan von dem
gesundheitsminister der dann gemeinsam
mit den ländergesundheitsministern
entwickelt und es vorgetragen werden wie
weit sie sind schon zur nächsten mp
konferenz die gute nachricht ist für
sonntag wissen wir jetzt bis 22 23
februar die liefertermine für die
anderen beiden impfstoffe nur bis 17.2
das ist wenn man bürgerinnen und bürger
ein lebende schlange insbesondere wenn
es hoch betagte menschen sind und wir
haben auch den herstellern glaube ich
sehr klar gemacht dass jede woche mehr
die sie uns etwas voraus sagen können
gut ist aber sie haben uns wiederum auch
verdeutlicht das finde ich auch
verständlich dass sie nicht mehr zu
sagen können als für sie redlich ist und
ich finde das thema transparenz aber
auch das thema redlichkeit was können
wir versprechen was können wir nicht
versprechen
in einem solchen prozess ist ganz
wichtig letzter punkt wir haben
natürlich auch gefragt wo können wir
unterstützen
und da gibt es einige punkte wo wir
aufgefordert wurden wir werden eine
plattform der bundeswirtschaftsminister
zusammen im vc entwickeln wo wir
transparent machen
in zwei bereichen insbesondere auf die
wir heute noch einmal hingewiesen wurden
ampullen und stopfen herstellung das
hört sich etwas trivial an aber wenn man
das nicht abholen kann dann kommt man in
schwierigkeiten und auch die für impfung
varianten also spritzen und ähnliches da
muss geguckt werden und auch bei
sensiblen bei seinen sieben substanzen
wie wir da alle möglichkeiten ausloten
werden um wirklich auch vielleicht noch
ein mehr an produktion möglich zu machen
es gibt zwischen stoffe die sind von so
entscheidender strategischer bedeutung
wenn man davon mehr hätte könnte man
auch mehr impfdosen produzieren hat man
inzwischen aber keine herstellung
hersteller und wenn wir da hilft
als sein können als politiker geld wird
es da nicht fehlen und an einsatz auch
nicht aber das hängt natürlich auch von
den fachlichen möglichkeiten ab also
insgesamt klarheit über die quartals
lieferung damit solidität für nach
jetzigem stand mehr kann ich nicht sagen
das versprechen dass wir ende des
sommers also ende des dritten quartals
oder ende des sommers am 21 september
ich weiß es jedem bürger ein angebot
machen können selbst wenn johnson &
johnson chor und klärwerk keine
zulassung bekommen
klarheit wie just in time die produktion
ist aber bund und länder werden
politisch versuchen durch modellierung
bestmöglich vorzuschreiben wie man das
größte maß an verlässlichkeit in die
voraussage der lieferung bekommen können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren